we are going to take a look at some
people that are in need of advice and as
always we've got some listeners who
wrote in with their questions and then
we've got one person who rather than
asking me for advice made the mistake of
going to Reddit instead and so we'll
help that person out as well this is
from Anonymous says hello Mr Walsh I was
hoping you could help me with a problem
I'm having I've been with my girlfriend
for four years now I plan on proposing
to her this year I know I know I should
have already done it by now I'm a bad
sweet baby anyway we've recently begun
to argue quite frequently about what to
watch on TV when we watch together she
likes to watch reruns of friends in
Seinfeld or early 2000s rom-coms not
that there's anything wrong with that no
of course not I like to watch good stuff
like Vikings and King of the Hill I'm so
depressed I can't even blink with some
generally awesome movies thrown in from
time to time she usually uh uses her
Magic Woman powers of guilt to sway me
into watching whatever absolute garbage
she wants to watch she thinks I'm having
bowel issues because I'm always going to
the bathroom but I'm really just sitting
on the toilet waiting for her episode of
Gray's Anatomy today and based will I
ever win this war is there a way to
balance this issue my Flawless taste in
entertainment is being polluted by stuff
like 90 Day Fiance and Big Brother side
note she's also Jewish and refuses to
watch Mel Gibson movies with me I get it
but come on I don't get it first of all
I don't get it at all because she's
Jewish can't watch Mel Gibson this film
is anti-Semitic and it must be stopped
if you're only gonna watch uh films or
shows that a star or were made by people
who've never said anything offensive or
unsavory or done anything offensive runs
every you basically eliminated
eliminated anything you could possibly
ever watch especially coming from Modern
Hollywood so I would even give her that
argument
um in general putting Mel Gibson aside
who by the way is one of the best
filmmakers currently even still working
in Hollywood if there were any justice
in the world which we know there's not
he would be given an Oscar with women
treat movies and shows the same way you
do restaurants listen where should we go
anywhere you want let's not think about
what I want how about anywhere you want
it's a cliche it's a stereotype but it's
also almost always true that women have
a difficult time deciding where they
want to eat and so you know I'm sure
you've had this conversation before
where you're in the car already where
you're decided what you want to get on
ubereats or something and you ask her
what do you want and and so I don't know
you pick and you say okay well uh then
here we'll go to Outback Steakhouse oh I
don't want that okay well instead okay
we'll go here and say oh I don't want
that other so she won't give you a clear
idea of what she wants but at the same
time if you throw an idea she doesn't
like that and you just have this back
and forth that's why when it comes to
what when you're going out to eat and
this is what I and I've I learned this
lesson a long time ago and so if I'm
going out with my wife we don't need
have a conversation anymore about where
we're going I'll make the reservations
and I'll say okay you know can you get
the babysitter for Friday night at six
o'clock and then she'll do that you know
she takes care of that and then I go I
make a reservation somewhere and she
doesn't even know where we're going
until we get there a lot of the times
and it and it works out I pick a place
that I know she'll like it's not like
I'm only trying to pick stuff that I'll
like pick a place that I know that
she'll like we don't have to have an
argument about where we're going I take
care of that I take the lead on that she
appreciates that more and really from
her perspectives like I've taken care of
so you don't have to worry about where
we're going to eat who ordered this the
gentleman did man most people generally
understand that with restaurants you
know and I think probably most women
wouldn't disagree with what I just said
it's a little more controversial with
movies and TV shows but I I think I try
to I think you have to adopt a similar
attitude where it's like you can come up
with shows that you know she'll like or
at least she should like them and so you
just gotta take the lead on that and say
listen here's a good show uh we're just
gonna put it on if I describe it to you
you might think you won't like it but I
think you will so let's just watch it
and you just take charge of you take
that remote you put it on and that's it
okay now it's a little bit awkward that
I'm giving us advice today after I just
admitted on the show that's what I did
on Valentine's Day and I put on a 1990s
Kurt Russell action flick on Valentine's
when she wanted a romantic comedy I'll
admit that that all like I thought she
would like it ultimately it wasn't a big
hit you're not gonna you're not gonna
bat a thousand on this thing you're
gonna make mistakes it happens but in
general Tech charge
take the remote put on what you know you
both will like all the advice I've just
given you take it at your own Peril
that's all that's the case for all this
I don't I don't take any responsibility
if I give advice and you and you run
with it I take no responsibility for
what happens after that you know people
are raving about genucel skin care
Jessica from Huntsville Alabama says my
skin looks so soft and clear I've seen a
reduced number of fine lines and dark
spots I have found a new lifetime
product absolutely love it gender cell
skin care uses a one-of-a-kind
proprietary flower base developed by the
founder and pharmacist along with rare
Botanical extracts and Powerful
antioxidants for skin care results that
work guaranteed genyourself skin care is
uniquely formulated which I have right
here all of my this is my own geniusell
skin care collection
it's like I collect I collect them you
know because I I'm a big user of this
product
um Fine Lines wrinkles dark spots
sagging jaw lines all of that can be
handled by genucel skin care their
products work for both men and women
plus they're safe for all skin types
you'll see results in 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back as I'm
always telling you my talent manager
Tessa uses genucel under eye treatment
to help get rid of the unsightly bags
under her eyes try geniusella's most
popular package for 70 off at
genucel.com Walsh YT join millions of
happy customers who've already fallen in
love with the results Plus for a limited
time get gen yourself probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com walshyt
genucel.com Walsh YT
from Samantha says Aloha Sweet Daddy my
future mother-in-law recently shared
that my fiance's sisters and their
husbands had all gone out to a strip
club together buying each other dances
and delighting in how the big girls
could make it to the top of the pole
from her perspective this was a
wonderful normal bonding experience I
was too aghast to respond and after she
left I asked my boyfriend what he
thought about it he simply said he would
never want to go to a strip club with
his family because it would be awkward
well this was an encouraging response I
haven't been able to let it go and I
don't mean to add to your problems I
don't know how encouraging that response
is actually I would never want to go to
my to a strip club with my family
because it would be awkward now correct
like it that is I can't imagine anything
more Awkward than that and you shouldn't
want to go to a strip club with your
family
um more encouraging response is uh I
don't want to go strip club at all maybe
that's a conversation you want to have
with them although I've always known his
family was more lewd and promiscuous
than mine the new level of debasement
debauchery and dysfunction the strip
club snafu reveals makes me extremely
uncomfortable I'm now even more
concerned about future outings with
these people and I certainly wouldn't
want to rear our future children around
this sort of immorality and Insanity my
boyfriend is extremely kind and isn't
the type of person to criticize his
family is there a way to Broach this top
topic without directly criticizing his
sisters their marriages and their
morality am I making a mountain out of
molehill you're not making a mountain
this is disgusting
first of all in general going to a strip
club in general it's like dirty grimy
disgusting places where you've got these
drug add old like women who are up on
the pole and everything you shouldn't
even really have any desire to go to a
place like you're just sitting around
with other with other creepy weirdos
like watching this it's disgusting in
general to go with your family or go
with your your spouse I mean just levels
of discounts like you take something
that's already gross and just add levels
of grossness on top of it and so you're
not at all wrong for um for seeing it
that way
and it does reveal something about
his family doesn't mean you hold it
against your fiancee he wasn't the one
who was there and it sounds like he
objects as well but it's good
information for you to know can you
Broach this topic with him without
directly criticizing his sisters and and
their marriages no you can't
um any attempt to Broach you without
being direct about it I think is is uh
not going to get you the result that you
want I mean you you have to address this
head-on especially with him doesn't mean
you're berating him about it or taking
it out on him certainly you don't want
to do that it sounds like you're not
doing that but just be direct like this
is wrong it's gross it'll reveals
something about these people that I'm
very uncomfortable with when we have
kids uh you know this is something I'm
going to take into account like I
wouldn't leave my kids with these people
given that their value system is so
wildly separated from your own and so I
think that's something that you want to
tell them and just be upfront about and
basically what you've told me it sounds
like you wouldn't even necessarily
disagree this is from Matthew says I'm
an 18 year old from South Australia
about six to seven months ago I started
talking to this girl call her Eliza from
Minnesota who I followed on Instagram
because she always posts epic based
things to her story a lot of which
concerned you we've been talking ever
since it's been really fantastic I've
never met anyone who not only has such
similar views and values to me but with
whom I can relate so deeply and
thoroughly I'm certain that she is the
perfect match for me to this end I've
decided I'm willing to at some point
when appropriate move to Minnesota and
do all that I can to be with her
fortunately for me she has a boyfriend
right now but I've spotted some
misalignments in their beliefs and hints
problems for their future she's also
said herself that I would be better for
her but she pictures it like those
tragic books where the main character
doesn't get to marry the right guy I'm
100 ready to wait for this girl and I've
actually already turned down several
offers from other girls in South
Australia I've been told by people
including my mother most recently last
night I shouldn't put all my eggs in one
basket I responded that she's telling me
to settle with which she disagreed is
waiting The Right Move am I wasting my
time is everyone who is saying long
distance doesn't work right I know it
doesn't but I haven't had a break in
conversation with this girl in seven
months what do I do wait get over there
and try to win over give up I'm in a
difficult spot thank you papa you're a
bloody legend love your workmate
um papa's Sweet Daddy Walsh is fine um
I'm gonna give you the bad news then
unfortunately
um Matthew great name and that is that
uh the issue is not that it's long
distance let me say that to begin with
long-distance relationships can be fine
they can work and in the modern age when
you can be in contact with someone and
even Australia to Minnesota is quite a
long flight but you can get on a plane
to fly and be there what doesn't work is
that she has a boyfriend and she's
talking to you and that she's been
talking to you what for six seven months
and she's had a boyfriend the whole time
uh and she's even saying to you so we
can't even let her off the hook here by
saying well maybe she doesn't realize
you know she's what this is she doesn't
realize you have feelings for sounds
like you both have had Frank
conversations and she's told you oh it's
one of those books where you're the
right guy but I'm with this guy and I
can't that is what tells me that you are
unfortunately wasting your time with her
and there are girls in your life who you
know oh
and you're rejecting them in favor of
this other girl who's with a boyfriend
uh you know I think that's a very bad
idea and to move from Australia to
Minnesota for this person who has a
boyfriend is also really bad let me tell
you why you know it's not that you're
wasting your time waiting like more than
likely in fact not more likely
guaranteed this girl
we'll eventually break up with this guy
that she's with I know that based on her
behavior it's not gonna last okay so
that's gonna so yeah I don't mean to
encourage you by saying that but she
will break up but she has revealed
something about her character it is so
bad so maybe her political values line
up with you maybe your ideological
values line up with you she's a fan of
mine which is great okay that's a big
Plus in her corner there that's one for
the win column but
um
even so
the fact that she's with someone and
yeah she's talking to you uh which is
which is betraying the person that she's
with it's dis it's dishonest to that to
that guy
and she's also stringing you along at
the same time oh this is like a romance
novel no it's not it's real life and
what she's doing she's playing games
with you and stringing you along and
she's lying to the guy that she's with
and I can guarantee you even if she
leaves that guy eventually and she uh
decides that she wants to be with you
how do you know she's not gonna do the
same damn thing to you in fact you'd be
pretty sure that you will and you're and
and uh
you think that you're going to be so
grateful and relieved if you ever won
the day you know you win the girl and
you get to be happily ever after what's
going to happen is you're going to
always be thinking about those six seven
months when you were talking to her and
telling her all your feelings and she
was talking to you while she was dating
somebody else and you're always going to
be wondering is she doing that now with
some other guy okay
so that's why this person is not worth
it you need to move on I hate to give
you
the bad news and actually I think we'll
leave it there well we don't even need
to move on to Reddit we've already given
some bad news and and uh something we
should all just take some time to let
sink in
times
of God too run away